welcome to this video trying to start a
five minute game here but somehow it is
not starting hmm takes quite a while so
i hope the audio setting is fine i did
make some changes for some reason the
audio in the last couple of videos has
been very bad and i'm not quite sure why
that is it's a very expensive microphone
Oh some way Evan was sound here why is
that just a second I need some sounds
okay lost a couple of seconds here
playing on an English opening probably
against semi noble from Russia I guess
Russia here and came yeah took of many
options also g3 but III is an
interesting line that I investigated
some time ago it needs to quit
development by white and some
interesting
night before what is he playing on a 30
you can do that but I've got very quick
development and I lost lots of time with
the night but of course my cling is only
two so in case of 91 I will be capture
I'm not quite sure why is thinking
Bishop f5 sisamuth he played Bishop f5
look sir looks bad to be honest but just
seems like a liability only form yeah we
probably will then take is cab night f4
maybe
and queen a forum could be a simple
solution maybe do that don't I want to
spend too much time and now I think
about all this can i play you for now
you can take and play Bishop g4
hmm
yes I could also as strange as it looks
I cannot do that and I thought I could
take on a seven actually Queen a seven
nights you one Roxy one but he's got
Bishop d3 which is quite embarrassing
hmm yeah maybe if I anyway take special
g4 I can we can maybe play that
I don't really don't really see a good
term continuation let's do this the
supports deform after to capture on c1
okay well then I'll do that you played
this esox move very quickly under now my
idea with rookie one makes some sense
okay I thought this was would simply be
excellent for white Air Force hanging
I'm threatening d5 I'm threatening to
take yeah you can try and try to do
something against my king but
essentially is just sacrificing lots of
material for insufficient compensation
yeah what is winning now but you can try
to do something on my time of course
that you takes d5 was a weird decision
now I'm winning the peace without Queens
on the board probably I should have
retreat anyway
got about one minute left
it should be enough actually check I can
take this Bishop no sew two pieces and
50 seconds should be manageable yeah I
thought very long in this opening check
check
just double on the seventh
yeah even the even the ruckus are
basically trapped here it can move on
the fourth-ranked put
yeah just be three next month
everything's covered they will win the
the Queen side now this is the easiest
problem
I'm warning what takes a five is made
I'm sorry my phone read moment to have a
phone call I've got 15 seconds but I
think he's in a meeting net nice brook
take that five looks like making net
yeah yeah I'm sorry for the phone call
nothing I could do about that maybe
should switch off the phone um yeah I
think Bishop f5 is really a very
demanding of this pollution but ok so
maybe ok don't know yeah yeah I spent
ages but I wasn't sure how to do that it
looks very shaky to me this position by
black because he is far away from short
castles and I just need to play d4 at
some point and it gets tricky okay rook
to you on the computer now gives a six
with the pic advantage don't really
understand why at the moment is it so
terrible I mean e6 is really bad and
quite obviously I think I know he's
played that after seven seconds I'm not
sure though why a six is so terrible for
me
check so a six I thought I could take I
mean and this is so own disastrous the
problem is the check here I thought I
still have something like you for but
the problem is look at this year that's
Queen d3 coming something like this J
now and the the big thing is also Knight
to h3 and rook g6 em yeah this was bad
look T one was bad move okay but he
played me six and after you for white is
just just winning here d 4head / f for
Hanks and d5 threatens blacks got
nothing developed and here in the game
not just just a piece up for nothing
yeah I needs to play this a six and then
it's got a good position so rocky one
was really really bad maybe I need to
play you for immediately it's maybe
possible I don't think that Bishop f5 is
good really maybe maybe I need to do
this something like this this could be
interesting something like this opening
up the position simplifying a bit and at
the end with queens of ie even have some
nice position for the king I think of
something like this yeah yeah and then
play this position where it's got a
slight weakness it's not a big deal
admittedly maybe maybe this isn't
possibility the night is not great on
the one but it protects this weakness
and I've got instant ideas here
something like this
I don't know interesting okay thanks for
watching